but you know i always say if you look
ugly wet you know there's no hope for
you man yeah
hello everyone hola miss amigos you're
listening to oh my god hi
with me george lopez
you know george is oh i'm sure he's
around here somewhere what's his name
all right we got a special guest reading
our ant today can i get a round of
applause everyone
today i'm excited to announce manscaped
launch their ultra premium collection
believe it or not it's for your not so
private parts i'm talking about a
leveled up hygiene routine with your
favorite manly scent ooh i love that
this is an all-in-one skin and hair kit
for the everyday man it covers you from
head to toe literally manscape is
trusted below the waist now trust them
with the rest join the 4 million men
worldwide who trust manscaped by going
to manscape.com for 20 off free shipping
with the code oh my god hi that's omg hi
free shipping manscaped get it nice and
scaped for your lady or your man
follow him and say hey man i'm running a
little bit late that's like a hole to
play don't do this anymore whoa they
just started like my flight was at
my flight was at seven from vegas got
there like 6 15. yeah chill got on at
before seven got here at 7 50 in the
morning
easy you land away from the burbank
airport
get your car whatever and go amazing
perfect
hell yeah
somebody will [ __ ] it or somebody will
go on there with a gun and [ __ ] it all
up for everybody else
yeah i won't take a gun on a plane
because they don't drink when you take
it you have to declare it first off but
if you do declare you can't drink oh
that's probably so [ __ ] i don't kill
him
declare you have a gun yeah i can't fly
with a gun yeah i can't you can't can't
how do you even declare it like yeah
you have to have a letter to send a
letter in in advance let them know
you're oh really yeah oh wow
i think uh
i think d.l hugo got arrested for having
a gun trying to take a gun to the
airport did he really what kind of gun
like a [ __ ] handgun like a 38 or
something
not a shotgun
yeah exactly got arrested
at lax
it was in a carry-on bag and he didn't
declare it
and
he eventually
the long version he they didn't file
charges on him
his wife had put it in there unbeknownst
to him that's a good word don't be
honest that's what you don't know
what's the penalty for that [ __ ] i don't
know why you never got caught yeah
cheers thank you so cheers never had one
excited you don't drink you're better
off yeah thank you you're better off
if i didn't drink maybe i'd look like
you yeah
oh that's great um
let's talk about our guests before we
get into them yeah the fact that i think
maybe we were white dudes in another
life where you guys might have been
chicanos in another there you go
in studying your podcast i'm like these
are hilarious these dudes are great and
it's like at what point when someone
tells you i think you're wasting your
time with all that [ __ ] like nobody
cares about that and then you see the
dudes that do care about it and are not
feel like they're wasting your time
and then you have kindred spirits like
you could never
it's [ __ ] hilarious watch anything
too much or know too much about
about anything so thanks for coming on
oh thank you thank you for the kind
words yeah yeah it's awesome yeah you
know one of the things about podcasting
is uh
you know from the things that i've done
the show like this girl right now hey
george lopez never
just george it's always george lopez
george [ __ ] george lopez
and last night i was walking back from
santana in las vegas and there was a
dude outside the foundation room in the
house of blues and he goes hey i love
the podcast
first time
all right i mean there's other people
but in person like i don't really try to
go out and do today
so if you go to the uh
i was with mine and i said um
you ever been up there and she goes no
i said i spent thirty five hundred
dollars up there in an hour what
four drinks at a tip
where she said
at the mandalay bay oh okay it's up at
the top
you know cause she's because i left the
girl uh
we went to see santana there's like a
suite like a james brown suite where you
overlook the stage
and um
it's just us you know and i left that
girl like a thousand dollar tip in mine
goes how much did you leave her i said a
thousand dollars
i go with she goes a thousand dollars
i said yeah that's
that's like you know your mom doesn't
have
[ __ ]
i'd have taken out your trash
a thousand dollars trying to work man
they're trying to make a living you know
yeah yeah
and if they sold me that sweet
it'd be like triple that to sit in there
and watch the show so
well we almost we almost went right you
know i looked up the flights everything
but when i looked up to mirage you were
sold out
[ __ ] that doesn't mean you can't
get in
[ __ ] come on you got the ass hey yeah
you got the access
doesn't mean for you
you're a busy man
hey you got some mexican that wants two
tickets over here
uh how did you guys meet
uh doing a four hose beer bong yeah at a
party yeah yeah and actually uh this is
the mount chug more
one of my buddies was on antibiotics so
he couldn't do his hose
we subbed in and yeah there was just
kind of an instant rapport like we made
eye contact while we were mid chug
there was a kind of yeah
i did yeah and one thing that was huge
is that jt applied the canola oil to the
funnel so the foam was you know on point
it was minimal yeah what's that what is
that so it just doesn't foam up at the
top if you put a little canola oil on it
yeah
who [ __ ] said who found that [ __ ] how
did you uh this kid
the drunken smell the canola oil the
first time we heard it from this kid
fernando who uh went to ucsb and then we
applied his techniques to the vehicle
okay so listen all you people out there
that drink that think you know how to
drink that maybe get crazy with a beer
bun once in a while i think maybe it's
in college and stuff like that
so in order to not get it to foam up
right
put a little canola oil
on the inside of it right here do you
notice it i mean no it's super subtle
and it slides out smoothly it goes out
real smooth and you don't get foam so
you don't lose out on any of the uh
volume dude this guy like two seconds
flat
yeah
i can open my gullet pretty well that's
really nice to you dude to say that how
do you open yourself of course i saw a
guy there was a guy named a comedian
named ollie joe prater back in the late
70s
that was a comedian you guys ever hear
about him no big country dude
big bell buckle
used to walk on stage with a coors light
and open his gullet and it'd go down
like that and he'd go waitress can i get
another one of these it has a hole in it
that was open in line
just go down right so as as he started
to drink and the older he got yeah they
would put a chair on stage and they
would cover him with a sheet
and then the other two comedians would
go on stage and then he'd be sitting in
the [ __ ] chair like this covered with
a sheet
and they'd go ready for your headliner
they'd go yeah they [ __ ] pull the
sheet that mama could be sitting in the
chair
because he was so big he couldn't walk
on stage so they would set them
on stage before the show started like
they would have seen people he would
like a grand piano he'd be sitting there
like this
and then they'd [ __ ] take the sheet
off and he'd it's like soft
he was waiting there
oh good old days before canola oil
that [ __ ] can put it down man
i mean it's something to be admired and
then at some point it becomes very sad
yeah but until then it's a it's a good
thing so so how do you open your
for
do you have to be born with it i was
going to say i think some people are
born with it and it's just something
that they instinctively know how to do
and they have the musculature in their
mouth and throat area to be able to
open it up like a clean pathway but i do
think there's things you can do to
improve to get to that level and i think
you're using a lot of the same muscles
they use in singing
so it's sort of like if you go to the
pinnacle of singing like i don't know
like andre abacelli doing the the prayer
come from that same operatic
base in your throat and sternum and then
that when you sing a song like that
you'll feel the muscles in your throat
kind of relax and it's the same thing
when you're hitting a beer bong so i
just try to sing something classical
before i put my mouth on the funnel
beer behind yeah
i wonder if he ever heard this
maybe he could start drinking out of a
beer bomb right but he's deaf right no
he's blind
is there a better beer to drink that
that's easier or or
yeah you know heavier beers are more
difficult but it's not so much in the
chugging process it's more the after
effects like you know if i'm chugging
three beers at a time and i do like a
heavy ipa
that's going to sink can you do that i
can do that but i'm so
i'm so committed to the dance floor that
if i do three ipas like that i know
that's going to cut into my grooves so i
try to stay with lighter beers i'm with
that if i'm trying to buggy
yeah uh you guys smoke weed for sure you
do i don't i you know i i i when i was
in high school you got to get the [ __ ]
out of here
i was in high school i really wanted to
be a star because everyone just saw me
they're like you're stoner dude and i
was like yeah that's my identity and
then i would smoke weed and how it would
have the opposite effect so i always
just figured i was just
now looks like he's on that level he's
got the thermal he's got the other shirt
on he's got the hat backwards i don't
need weed you you know you i think if
you look like you get high why get high
yeah
you know what if you look like you could
drink and like you've been up all night
[ __ ] it just look like it if i if i
smoked weed i probably would have walked
in here with like a suit and tie
that's your that's your vibe right there
yeah
yeah yeah yeah that's how i present yeah
yeah yeah so i saw you guys were talking
about you know i watched the sopranos a
lot like i've seen over and over and
over and over greatest show of all time
it is right better than breaking bad i
think so better than um
i'm ozark yes
and what do you think made it what do
you think made it so good i mean the
character so you got like silvio dante
that's not an actor
he's got a wig clearly he's got the you
know the way he talks you know when he
walks
you know like a kind of a penguin guy
right but it works right yeah like he's
not a projector yeah he's perfectly
casted in that part i think it's the
most complete psychological portrait
i've ever seen of a human being in art
like i think you see every dimension of
tony soprano's personality and it all
feels cohesive
this doesn't sound like anybody that i
was listening to on youtube or anything
you're saying you're serious on this
though i get fired up when i talk about
the surprise oh man
yeah and you know they punch each other
a lot and that's cool too
yeah the uh because i've seen it and i'm
you know i was in um in the early 2000s
when my show started they had a podcast
i think they were they had a not a
podcast but they had a radio show the
guys sopranos uh and um
they were the kings of new york
like they could go to any restaurant
and even though they were actors playing
uh you know gangsters
it's like the i mean why be a gangster
in new york when you can be an actor
playing a gangster
and have everybody from every restaurant
i don't care where it is rails wherever
anybody can't get in and these dudes
could just stroll in
and be kings how did the sopranos match
up to the godfather
gentlemen
i think it's better yeah i think i mean
it's
because it has the humor in it it's a
great question
the godfather was good because of
the the attention to detail you know
of uh you know that guy out there uh
practicing uh luke brazzi practicing
what to say
the the technique of you can't deny
somebody something on the on his
daughter's wedding day you can ask for
something that the the guy that was an
issue he made him a cake you know took
care of it
and i think that from the family and
that big party which that house is over
there off of like cold water you think
oh really i think it's back east it's
it's out there off coldwater canyon at
the top of two or the downward bottom
number one yeah uh uh we're number one
right it's right there it's like people
think it's back east it's it's what i
thought it's in the base of beverly
hills oh that's awesome so so it's a
it's a different vibe i mean
psychologically yes but you know it
seems like in the movies that they three
hours to get to
the end of one and then two and then
they go to cal neva and then fredo
and all of that things that stand out as
like i'm i'm a smart guy
all of that but in the sopranos they
have that
within the hour like
every episode at least once or twice
sometimes even more in in in
the body of the sopranos
so if anybody's not seen it i don't
think you know a show has to be new in
order for somebody to have binge watch
it or get enough of it yeah and if
anybody's out there that has not seen it
i mean it's in spanish and all that
stuff but from the beginning
it's just so so chill yeah yeah i i
i was gonna i was gonna watch the pilot
just to do like a synopsis of it for
like a little video
and it was my second time watching it
and then it just hooked me like from the
pilot i just had to i just had to finish
the whole series again when i when i was
watching the promos war because when i
when i was doing my show in 2002
and they start to come to you with like
what the fonts gonna be like what the
what the
show's gonna look like you know and uh
there was this guy i think it was called
a ring of fire that did
logos
so we sat in there and the guy from ring
of fires had these almost like flash
cards and he's like okay we did this
and they did the sopranos and it said
the sopranos and the p was the gun like
a glock
just like [ __ ] brilliant
and then they showed me mine which was
like a bobble head
with the red black and white and all of
us were like they had me in a van and
they had like me away from just the
thing and then when they did the font it
was
perfect so when watching
hbo and watching the lead up to the
sopranos which she goes are we are you
in the mafia and he's like what
you know you look at it whatever you
heard for stereotype
yeah yeah and you think
i don't know man i don't think that show
is going to work and it's [ __ ] great
yeah all the time and paulie was in the
mob right yeah yeah because i think
that's why he
he has the hands you know he holds his
hands up because it's like to they're
always at the ready yeah he can always
fight uh it's like a defensive thing oh
wow from the mob and the writing of it
is good and then you know i think you
know we did a show and they were saying
that out of the darkness you know it
might be a little too heavy
uh you know the shows but
they had a way of cutting the the the
tension with humor you know
that when when vito was uh you know fond
of vito
was homosexual and right then that was
something that really shocked me
because you never
in my wildest imagination that's the
mafia you never think that they'd be gay
right
and it showed that he was homosexual and
then he met uh um
frank vincent who played what was his
name with the white hair oh
phil leotard
yeah yeah and they meet at the uh at the
bud costello
uh statue
and they said you know how about having
a phenoik in your crew and he's like
he sucks some dick it's a victimless
crime
i mean that [ __ ] is justice like man you
know comics would be looking for [ __ ]
like that yes if you write one of those
and they're just all the and the ma and
the mom
oh poor you like everybody either mom or
grandmother did that mm-hmm yeah you
know
and uh
yeah i think you know does it get the
attention i don't i don't think so much
do you think you think people rate it
and sign
i think what's that streaming and all
that stuff
i think so i think i think it's still
recognized as probably one of the top
top shows in history and then i think it
was so pivotal for the way tv is now
like you started that golden age yeah
television yeah you know you had like
timothy van pat they had a lot of
directors that you wouldn't think would
be good at directing in like an hour of
like gritty
gritty uh uh comedy van patten
and a lot and a lot of the guys uh
but uh
when
i think we all hosted the emmys in 2005
and that was like in the heyday of then
so they were sitting there i mean you're
sitting there for
[ __ ] it seemed like seven hours yeah
and the guys on my show handed out
water
and breath mints that had water that had
my the name of the show on it and breath
mints in between the commercial they got
mad like hey i said hey
they're doing it
we went to this we gave it to edward
william grace we gave it to
uh sex of the city
and the sopranos and they the he gave it
to gandolfini and edie falco and they
were like
oh there's our favorite guy right there
gave him some water and some mints
you're sitting there for seven hours
yeah and they won they won emmys that
night and you hosted it yeah we hosted
it now was that fun it was it was pretty
crazy you know and i just started kind
of getting into the
inter kind of tv 2003 four five
so that was the year that
myself conan brad garrett
uh bernie mac gary chandling um i think
ray romano and brad garrett all kind of
shared hosting duties
and um
when it was i i gave the emmy out for
the first reality tv survivor uh
survivor you know they had the email so
i had to go out there and do
you know material about you know game
should i said you know
big brother
14 people living in the house it's been
done
you know
yeah and i said uh
extreme makeover they take somebody ugly
in an hour they're beautiful i go isn't
that what a 12-pack used to do
[Laughter]
like that yeah and before i went out
there's [ __ ] nervous man so i look
around the corner
i look around the corner and you see
everybody that's on tv
and in the middle of the front row is
[ __ ] robin williams and robin
williams looks at me and he goes like
this like like giving you strength
[ __ ] yeah yeah i said all right it
goes like this
nice and uh that helped me out man do
people get mad when they don't win
well eddie murphy took off i mean ever
thought he was gonna win for uh dream
girls he [ __ ] left he got up and
nobody no listen you get mad when you
don't win but nobody [ __ ] gets up and
leaves
because he thought he was going to win
he went he stayed i think from mr church
too that he got nominated and he thought
i'm gonna win for dream girls
they show all your listen man they did
it to me at the [ __ ] 2009 grammys
they show your face
and you [ __ ] lose you're just like
mother [ __ ] they cut away
but i know the camera's on you right
yeah yeah and he got up and [ __ ]
he's like i'm done what was it was it
hard to keep your composure when you
knew the camera was on you yeah because
you try i mean you don't want to make a
face because you know it's like you know
you kind of have to be used to it so you
see the guy there and you know and then
the winner is stephen colbert mother
[ __ ]
you gotta clap yourself
but you know it's interesting man
because as as
you know we got older
people get younger and it's like the
things that
that we don't know about as being older
kind of give somebody away you know
like the shows that we would watch or
the fact that the music that we would
listen to
you know if somebody were to say to me
so what kind of music are you into and i
would say like
i'm still into like the 70s rock and 80s
and oh yeah and everybody's moved on i
think right
a lot of those dudes are those dudes are
not alive anymore it's kind of hard
listening to
some music when the whole band is gone
yeah right
exactly where can i see them ah
what is he talking about we talk about
like you know i when i was on the radio
in 2000
the ohio players and they had fire and
they had uh with one fire they still had
back then
ohio has had the um
fire
don't you know
yeah uh i like some hoods in them yeah
yeah and they
love roller coasters
yeah yeah
and uh
i saw in the paper one time that the
last dude passed that said all the dudes
from ohio players are
last of the temptations just passed this
last year too whoa no way really all
temptations are gone
who was the lord thompson was it david
ruffin uh no david ruffin went a long
time ago melvin franks went a long time
ago
one of the williams uh one of the
brothers yeah those guys williams refin
was kind of a dick right they dropped
them off at the hospital man like just
dumped them off really oh when he passed
yep
oh whoa like take you to the emergency
and just leave you and then drive off
yeah i had a buddy take me to the
emergency room and he left after like 20
minutes
i was like yeah man all good all good
how did you end up with an emergency i
just did too many drugs one night oh
[ __ ] yeah i think it was more mental
than physical like i think my central
nervous system was just a little taxed
and so i just went in there
to make sure everything was still uh i
love [ __ ] love that functioning
properly they put the masks they put the
mask on you you take it up i think my
central nervous system is just a little
bit textured
that is how i talk to the doctors too
i want these doctors to know i'm
self-aware
if your [ __ ] central nervous is taxed
whatever you say because they know you
know maybe you know there's nothing
you're going to say oh yeah it's all
right let him he'll walk it off
no he can drive you know do you ever let
somebody drive that that couldn't drive
i think we all
sure sure i try to step up but yeah
sometimes it's hard to stop so the worst
is when they go we'll follow you
yeah
how does that help
[ __ ] up like oh hey man we'll follow
you and then you're behind me he's like
oh [ __ ]
i remember giving up my keys because i
knew i'd had too much to drink giving
them thanks
and they said here jack's going to take
he'll go get your car
i said okay he says where's your car he
says
i'll find it and he took off running we
were at dodger stadium he had to run the
whole stadium to find my car and he's
running away i'm saying go get my keys
back i'm not that drunk
i'm giving her a [ __ ] drug right and
he eventually made it back though
good thing he was a runner how did you
guys start to start doing the podcast
and and how did you start gaining you
know the kind of following that you guys
have we we so we started doing these
city council uh videos where we started
activism where the first thing was we
wanted to build a paul walker statue to
unite the nation and then we were
fighting for house parties you know
because they were under threat in the
hollywood hills
and those went viral so
at that point and then we sort of gained
a little bit of a following so then
there are you know these young bros
following us and it's like okay so let's
talk about the paul walker i paul walker
on my uh my talk show great guy yeah
fast and furious so
uh somebody reminded me in the body of
our interview
that he lived in like monrovia yeah or
up there right
so he would he would
skateboard
down foothill but like it was a pretty
steep uh thing so he'd skateboard down
there
and he would go through the red lights
and he didn't know if cars were coming
or not whoa
and he would just go through the red
lights and he said
it always it always worked out for me
like i always i never got in danger he
almost got hit a few times yeah and he
would go through there i mean that's
[ __ ] danger yeah because you don't
know what cars are coming
and then you know with the accident the
way that happened is a guy called me and
said like you know all that time he
would say it went my way
that he wasn't driving but
you only have so many of those you only
have so i think you only have so many of
those right yeah he must have found some
peace and that risk like doing that must
have kind of
i think there is
something to that oh yeah yeah you know
i mean gill talked about
a [ __ ] fellow police officer shooting
at him
and [ __ ] missing like what are the i
mean to get shot at by another officer
who who's trained with a gun but then he
[ __ ] misses yeah yeah a little bit
we're just fired which is crazy
i mean
you you didn't know if he was going to
miss [ __ ] thing because
you know
and the guy now the guy doesn't know
that these guys are cops right thinks
why did you guys pointing guns at the
guy inside and he's like drop the gun
and [ __ ] shot at him yeah whoa what
did you so
he shot at you and you were okay
yeah what do you do after that ma'am
like were you jacked up like how did you
oh yeah we jumped the car to get the
other side and had another gun my
partner was really pissed
i don't ever panic i don't get bad i
don't get pissed
my partner was livid and i just said
it's okay partner i got another gun
right here and i pulled one out my leg i
said if you're gonna shoot again i'll
dump him and i was con i was confident
that i could dump him i wasn't gonna
miss
i said he shoots a gift he's gonna shoot
again i'll dump him
but didn't have to because his partner
who knew we were cops started screaming
you stupid mother [ __ ] you know we
were playing clothes
but we had those big raid jackets they
wouldn't say sheriff on the back you
know
and
the glasses you can get now at like the
flea markets yeah exactly
and and the gangsters making me not want
to get they knew
they knew we were cops
you know they thought it was cool and
this guy comes up and now he wants to
beg for you and i said [ __ ] this don't
worry about me you better take care of
that guy you got in custody you know
you're trying to arrest
otherwise you're gonna have a problem
those guys are gonna lynch him you're
gonna have a big [ __ ] fight on your
head you take care of your problem don't
worry about us we're alive mm-hmm and so
that's all it was
those [ __ ] cholos on their patio were
like [ __ ] don't do anything man
they'll kill each other
he eventually got fired he got fired for
what he did really oh wow yeah he just
went through vapor lock it was his 12th
day out on the street
and
his the guy that did his investigation
said that a mack truck
10-ton mack truck gone by and sounded
its horn he never would hurt it he's
winning the vapor lock all he saw was
big gun and you know yeah the rook he
was new and adrenaline he loves it so
what's that phrase paper lock vape vapor
lock what is that what is the vapor lock
though
nervous system go say wire that just
happens like a car when you go into
vapor lock it just stops it freezes and
that's what happens you know he just he
just froze you know you can't hear
anything you can't see anything he went
totally out of everything he was focused
on one thing he saw two guys with guns
that's how i am before i hit the beer
bomb
we all know how essential the manscaped
lawnmower 4.0 is for the precise trim
below the waist their advanced skin safe
technology reduces cuts to your most
delicate areas but now you can enhance
your perfect grooming routine with their
ultra premium collection this package
includes manscape premium deodorant no
not for your balls for your stanky
armpits it dries clear it's aluminum
free and smells like their signature
manscape scent has a hydrating body
moisturizer tattoos or issues with dry
skin it's designed to keep skin feeling
smooth clean and smelling fresh also
comes with a body wash to lather you up
infused with aloe vera sea salt shower
gel two in one shampoo and conditioner
to clean your scalp with an easy single
step plus a free gift a three pack of
lip balm that's made up with ingredients
such as vitamin e peppermint and
eucalyptus oil to keep those choppers
feeling moist you don't want to put that
near your oil though you cook this
get to get 20 off plus free shipping
with the code omg hi at manscape.com
that's 20 off and free shipping with the
code omghi
manscape.com the power of attraction is
now in a bottle thanks to manscaped
is there a beer bong championship like
like like on fourth of july when the
guys eat all those hot dogs you know
it's not so much about chugging speed
it's about length of beer bong so people
are always pushing the envelope that way
and trying to create a longer and longer
beer bong and it's something that chad
and i are pretty committed wait wait a
minute wait a minute all right so
normally
in my day
whatever you could hold it whatever you
could hold up here was the length of
that right [ __ ] hardware store and
get some aquarium tubing or whatever
like clear tube we call those autonomous
beer bombs
right
uh uh yeah and then uh so what what's
the what's the longest
longest
man around 100 feet i think we have our
buddy yeah our buddy frodo studied
physics at cal state fullerton he's
trying to guess he's trying to make a
120 foot one for us
so uh and uh he just he's doing all the
equations but sky's the limit once we
hit 120 we're going to want to push to
140 then we'll see what did you go on
top of a building and stuff like that at
some point i'd like to be able to sears
tower or yeah you know empire state
building and just
see if we can work it out it's like when
i saw that dock man on wire about the
dude who tight roped across yeah yeah
the world trade center i was like what
if that was a beer bomb
yeah that was instantly where my brain
went we had this other idea about uh
using a drone because the sky's the
limit there you could just take you know
you saw like a felix baumgardner who did
the free fall yeah just you know drone
it up however long you want
or uh or a hot air balloon hot air
balloon yeah that'd be sick yeah
you have a nice day
[Laughter]
one thing you have to worry about is
inertia this thing called inertia
because when the beer bond comes from
like a huge height oh my god it's going
to
just
terminal
yeah yeah yeah it can flatten you yeah
yeah like when people say you drop a
penny off the empire state building it
like kills someone yeah it's like that
but with like a course yeah magic cores
come in yeah
how fat i mean would you do that i don't
know hell no
you could totally do it yeah i'd love to
do it yeah i think you'd [ __ ] rip it
dude excuse my language i really like it
super chill yeah no i think you would
crush that dude ah
are people still bear bombing for sure
we're trying to keep it alive i mean you
know everything's you know it's kind of
like fashion it's in it's out but we try
to always keep it
on the runway of our lives yeah how did
the the paul walker statue end up
it's still uh still we're still in the
process there's that where the on the
site or where in brazil we want to do it
on the san clemente pier um and so we
talked to the city of san clemente and
they're like wait it's not in our budge
uh so we're trying to work that we try
to go fund me and then we're just gonna
do we're just gonna keep trying to raise
money to get what what's how much you
guys need
probably about a hundred thou because we
want to get you we want it to be like
legit like bronze statue and you have an
idea of what it looks like we can put it
up on the yeah we do have some images i
don't know if we could like easily pull
them up but yeah
yeah
i'll drop them in if we could yeah yeah
we can send them to you post and then uh
but yeah we know what we want we just
wanted to embody his chillness like he
was such a chill laid-back guy and i
think he
was able to make other people feel that
way and we want the statue to do that
for everyone who
you know comes to san clemente and
integrates there and stuff we want that
to be the first thing they see who's a
politician you're trying to nail when
you were on one of your uh
youtube things and and you're trying to
get them to commit to uh
the statute oh who are we talking we
talked
about politicon that might have been
roger steele the former head of the rnc
yeah yeah and uh he seemed like
he seemed like he was gonna go for it
yeah yeah i think yeah we got some heavy
hitters who are on the fence it's just a
momentum thing once one of them falls
the rest of them will
follow suit yeah but we have tons of
ground support you know yeah yeah yeah
yeah of course
yeah yeah i think it's a good thing i
mean listen man they're taking down
general lee and all those statues let's
put some statue up that you know will
certain survive the test of time yeah
fair share everybody love paul walker
yeah he's exactly he sat across with me
and when he walked that was like the
number one movie that we could [ __ ]
huge
and uh
he sat down and people went crazy in the
commercial he i said so what do you guys
do man you just make a movie that white
black latino asian men
girls attractive people
and everybody wants to go see got pretty
much i mean
is everybody in there yeah i think that
was the drift movie where they were
drifting yeah yeah
or paul wasn't in tokyo drift no no no
those are fast and furious but but
something oh it might have been number
five
yeah yeah cause they when they have the
safe behind the two chargers there's a
lot of drifting yeah yeah one of the
better
car chase scenes in history for sure
that's a good one yeah
yeah i've really sort of changed the
trajectory of that it did right turns
into a heist thing yeah have you been in
a high-speed chase
yeah
is that exciting yeah very much so hell
yeah it is if uh if you watch the movie
end of watch
they open up the movie with a good
chasing yeah and that's exactly the way
it is in the car because you're talking
with your partner and you're sitting
there saying get that [ __ ] oh
clear right clear left yeah get that no
[ __ ] him you know you're yeah you're
yelling at each other and it's exciting
you're fired up yeah do you wear your
seatbelt
uh not during the pursuit
yeah
that's the only time you because that
thing hinders you you got to be able to
get out and you got to be able to get
out of the car in a hurry so interesting
the only time i ever wore my seat belt
when i was in uh patrol was during uh
rain
what if you're taking fire and the
[ __ ] windshields
and you're [ __ ] going i can't
you're [ __ ] stuck in here the law and
the policy says buckle up but
[ __ ] you no no this is my life you know
i want to be able to get out i want to
be able to do this and certainly if you
were in a bad wreck you may be ejected
we didn't back then nobody gave a [ __ ]
about ejector there was no clicking or
ticket or anything like that right right
so it was just no seat belts or any
pursuits
seat belts onto the right in my life
what car was that though those were the
cars that
i mean
i saw a highway patrol that
wasn't what the [ __ ] did they use that
was so fast like a [ __ ]
that thing looked like
was it a charger they used chargers they
used to use chargers one of the fastest
cars we use it just had a light ass in
it was fun to drive was uh the nova
chevy nova it was small it
get up and go real quick and quick take
off quick acceleration good handling it
was just light in the ass in you know
yeah i drive my prius is out front
sick but those i mean the the the teslas
and all those cars now that that go zero
to 60 in no time
it's too fast it's like two seconds it's
you've been in one of those that goes
that fast it [ __ ] takes off man
and now i'm just the opposite they're
slow now and there's no pull to it yeah
you hit it and you just and you just go
there's no
none of that
there's not like that moment where the
car is like charging up for it it's just
yeah yeah two point three seconds they
got it down to zero to 60. does your
head go back at that wow
acceleration
i feel like they should add car sounds
to tesla
you know what i almost got [ __ ] hit
by one you're just silent yeah
yeah
you need it and also just for like the
thrill when you're gonna go that fast
you need to i like to hear it you can do
that off some car alarms yeah you want
the corresponding
senses
[Laughter]
you know when my daughter
was only two and a half she broke her
elbow she was in the hospital for two
weeks
and she shared a room with a little
african-american little girl
and went down to talk to her one day and
her older sister was there and she said
see your daughter says you're the
policeman i said yeah i'm the policeman
he says oh
she says where do you work i said
sheriff's department and she says oh i
said where do you live
she said east compton and i said well
the sheriff's department they handle you
should no no it's not sheriff's
department
i said okay what color are the uniforms
are they black she says no they ain't
black
and i said okay are they blue she says
well no they ain't blue
i said well the only other uniform color
around there would be tan and green says
yeah that's it i said well that's
sheriff's department that's mighty bar
that's who i work for they work out a
firestone station covering these
competitions that's at five stone
everybody knows them as firestone
and i said really she says yeah we just
like sitting on the corner listening to
chef hum
and i said what do you mean he listened
to the sheriff um back then they were
using uh
either the chargers or the fury so you'd
hit that corner and
hear them home you know you could hear
the carburetors kicking yeah we just
like sitting on the corner listening to
chef huh
a fury
nobody talks about the fury i never even
heard of that one yeah i don't know yeah
they they made a lot of noise didn't go
that fast they made it
was that a dodge yeah
you're saying plymouth yeah plymouth
plymouth fury what are you guys on
training day you guys uh the film yeah
yeah i love it yeah awesome well i
watched it again like two months ago
david ayer yeah i guess the dude who
originally was gonna make it got kicked
off the project because denzel wanted to
work with antoine fuqua and then that
guy went on to make the documentary an
inconvenient truth with al gore who is
that what's his name david guggenheim i
think
and
and then you can you know there's not a
lot of
similarities between the two projects
davis
davis
dave who's davis google and i'm married
to uh oh
he's married to somebody named elizabeth
hugh thank you brother whoa elizabeth
shoes got the facts one of my all-time
favorites what oh great she's incredible
where do you like her and what leaving
las vegas no i'm kidding uh she was good
she was good in that but it's a very
tragic tragic i would say the boys i
like her in she's in karate kids karate
baby probably
i would probably go karate and i know
that's the obvious pick but i just i
love that man yeah she was cool doesn't
that remind you like of like when you
like somebody in junior high or high
school and it's so like
you know so young and you know there was
this girl that when we graduated from
high school in 79
we all went to go see santana at the
universal amphitheater
and it was open air back then and then
there was this girl susie
that i liked and i you know we were out
of school and you know we were hanging
out and went to the concert together she
goes are you going to this party like
we're going to this party afterwards and
then this guy showed up that she was
kind of dating and then he like
like she left with him
and i never [ __ ] saw her again um
wow man because we were
i think at the at the concert i bought
some some cracker jacks i had the box
and i had the thing in there so we were
like
messing with the toy and the dude
rolls up and like takes her
and [ __ ] never saw her
yeah that's brutal
i have a lot of moments like that yeah i
was driving down the rail one time and i
saw this beautiful girl walking her mom
across the street and i was like yo
that's like my wife and then i was like
maybe i should pull over and say
something i never did i think about it
all the time but what would you i mean
can you pull over and say something to
me i don't think you're allowed to
anymore that's the thing how can people
freak out yeah but i think i would have
done well in a society where that was
okay and i don't think i would have
pushed it too hard
you guys aren't married though no no no
no would you want to get married i
definitely want to get married have some
kids yeah but i don't know i want it to
happen when it's supposed to yeah i
think that's the only way to
to get married uh i was married for 17
years
and my daughter's 25 you know we have a
thing but but i'm 60
and i don't think that i would
even be in a relationship
i don't i don't know how long i'm going
to live
but it is going to be
where nobody says to me you're golfing
didn't you go off yesterday
you go
you're going to go off three days in a
row
what time do you what time did you get
back what time did you leave well at
eight and what time did you get home
like 7 30. you were golfing all day yeah
that's the [ __ ] that's a
that was surfing that's what i say on
first day i'm like surfing number one
top priority so you know the waves are
pumping i'm out there
but surfing is something that how did
you start you grew up around the beach
and all that yeah yeah uh and i started
when i was like 13. it's not easy no you
got to stay consistent with it because
that muscle memory kind of fades after a
little bit so it's not like you know you
can it's not like riding a bike you just
always have to maintain that so so what
length of board do people use when
they're when you're you're probably more
advanced right so the longer the board
the faster
yeah so you use longer boards bigger
boards for bigger waves uh if you're on
the more advanced level you also use
long boards for like beginners and
you know longboarding but um i ride like
a 510 channel islands board which is
you know standard short board size and
you know that's probably for like four
to
eight ten feet
um and you wax it people whack some
relax it makes it a little faster right
yeah
yeah and have you traveled the world
surfing i've gone to hawaii uh mexico
uh costa rica australia and bali
yeah
so and what's that like
you imagine going on a plane to bali and
you got your board with you but you most
people go to
sightsee you're going to [ __ ] surf
yeah bali's sick it looked and the whole
it's like it's a it's an amazing place
and the waves are you know it's reef
breaks so there's you know like um
what's the one um uluwatu uluwatu yeah
it's it's like shallow and you know
karamas is like a fun beach break there
yeah it's like you know it's it's
it can get big and dangerous but it's
but yeah
and and does somebody say or see you out
there and say like like almost like they
if you were at a skate park where they
go hey man that dude's [ __ ] skating
down the wrong way or right yeah is it
was surfing is there somebody that maybe
you wipe out yeah or you get in the way
of somebody and they're like yo man you
gotta you're [ __ ] not in santa cruz
that's that's probably where i see it
the most because like they're it's cold
water and they're like they're hardcore
there and you know
there's one guy it's steamer lane out
there he's on a rental board and he
everyone knew and this one local was
just like dude you gotta get the [ __ ]
out
he's like what do i do he's like what'd
you do you're on a rental board you're
wearing gloves and no booties you're
disrespecting the spot
that do kelly slater so kelly slater
played in the att in the golf tournament
yeah so we would play on a wednesday
like a like the celebrities play and
then at that 18th hole you know
everybody goes and eats that
[ __ ] went out to still water
cold when he was surfing in stillwater
cold oh wow wow which was crazy man
cause like you're out there yeah an hour
earlier he was your [ __ ] teammate an
hour later he's out there [ __ ]
surfing the sun's going down [ __ ]
amazing he's a machine amazing one time
in my life went to hawaii with buddy
mike was getting married that's where
he's honeymooning and he's an old surfer
and he wanted me to rent a board let's
run boards and go on out there and go
surfing
this body doesn't go [ __ ] surfing you
know what he did he talked me into the
board and i thought i was gonna drown
because
i i'd get up on that board i couldn't
get far past my knees
and then all of a sudden i lose my
balance and now i'm going under so i'd
hold onto the board because i know that
floats
and now i'm under water and i'm laughing
underwater
because i know that's the [ __ ]
everything right i'm laughing underwater
and i'd get back up and now he's
laughing because he's laughing at me
because i'm making an ass on myself was
out there for an hour finally said [ __ ]
this let's go back in so i go back
inside and big hawaiian big look samoan
he said here he says hey how come they
give you that little board that bought
too little you need big boys
[Laughter]
and
it was fun i guess i laughed but i was
scared i was under the water listen man
all that [ __ ] that [ __ ] make
look graceful is the hardest [ __ ] to do
like that like you got to get you got to
get up
and then your feet are like they're
they're stuck to the board like dudes go
on they go in the in the in the tunnel
or the tube and they're touching the
water to know where they are i mean that
[ __ ] is amazing man yeah when you see
someone when you see a really good
surfer in person or getting barreled
it's it's pretty mesmerizing it's like
it's like it's like art yeah like you
get a lot of but you get a lot of chicks
like you know they come out like
everybody looks better wet like you see
michael phelps driving you ever seen me
you ever seen me in speedos
but you know i always say if you look
ugly wet you know there's no hope for
you man yeah you know
i had an hbo special i said you seen
them [ __ ] you seen them michael
phelps dry go like
everybody looks better wet they come out
with the board you're wet like chicks
are right there like oh my god i mean
it's [ __ ] is there a better calling
card for chicks than yeah for them to
see you out there death defying [ __ ] and
then you roll up wet that's so true
i think now when i go to like bars or
something i'm just gonna dunk my head
before i get in there you can have my
buddy pour one liter of dasani over my
head would it be if you went to a bar
and they had a hose out there you get
the [ __ ] wet yourself before you win
it
swirlies are about to make a cupcake
yeah yeah good call yeah that'd be sick
if they came back yeah
and you still do you still do it huh you
guys golf or anything you guys go we go
we golf a little yeah we're actually
about to do a city council speech about
golfing yeah yeah so we you know we
always fight for causes and they moved
the tea box at the san clemente
municipal course uh and they took away
the ocean view on it and it's just
totally depleting stoke for all the
local players so we're going to go in
there and request that they move the tee
box back to its
i guess it was like hitting some dude's
crib but he wasn't even getting that
much ball traffic and i guess the new
t-box is even he's even more vulnerable
now to aaron shots so you know what i
golf i i want to uh help you guys do
that really yeah dude you would be a
huge ally [ __ ] get you on board let's
[ __ ] back up all the time yeah you
understand that because we think it's so
important for like the cultural stoke to
have a hole where you can just see the
ocean and just feel totally in nature
while you're you know shucking okay so
[ __ ] i absolutely said it so
over there in pacific grove by monterey
like you can pay
900 or [ __ ] a grant a thousand
whatever it is to play pebble beach or
you can go to pacific grove and play
right on the ocean same ocean and it's a
public course and you don't pay as much
and there's houses there and all you
need is somebody to [ __ ] about [ __ ]
ball going in your yard but they've
always gone to the yard since they built
those houses and you know that when you
buy that crib that you're in like you're
in the splash zone yeah yeah
so you should come to
the council tomorrow
tomorrow tomorrow what's that clementi
six o'clock
george i'm counting on you like now i'm
expecting is it in the morning
in the afternoon
it's public comment we all get three
minutes but if we could have someone of
your station and influence backing our
cause we could literally change this
golf course
change the city stoke and from there
the sky's the limit i think change of
the world yeah that's what i wanted to
say but i was too nervous and modest i
george that would really put us over the
top i'm going to go i'm going to and up
into this moment in my head i was
calling you mr lopez but now that we're
bonding over this your channel i
switched to georgia
at this point
i'm gonna [ __ ] go in the morning i'm
gonna get a hotel because i got some
appointments in the afternoon and at six
o'clock i'm gonna [ __ ] be with you
guys yeah let's [ __ ] go let's do this
this is how change happens like-minded
people you'll be with your [ __ ] wife
[ __ ] nachos on your [ __ ] balcony
hey you want me to go let's go
with you
i'll go with you i know you told us
before this you don't like to golf so i
appreciate you being an ally even though
it's not something that's a man one more
thing you get to call him g-lo you get
to call him jordan he still makes me
call him mr lopez
until we complete our stress test
[Laughter]
i'm down with that but yeah because we
just we just think like golfing is
really important for
the mind right like is there no question
is there a better escape for you and
your bros to kind of decompress that's
why i started playing we started playing
on christmas day vfw 1980 yeah dfw
going there and everybody's pissing all
over each other uh uh
all the all the veterans go what the
drinks are like a dollar yeah yeah
that's it it's better when you're a
veteran
they'll give you about also at my
country club at lakeside
you know you never see them pour the
drinks thomas will put this much vodka
can i have a
vodka cranberry this much vodka
and that much cranberry i mean you're
just like what the [ __ ] what do you mean
you wanted a bunch of cranberries right
yeah you doing yeah
they pour a man they do they do good
they form do you think tomorrow if it
went well that it we could get it over
the top i think so i think so because
they uh according to our sources they
didn't really have like it wasn't really
fair like it wasn't really debated
somebody just decided they just decided
yeah some people and i don't want to be
i don't want to speak without real
evidence but i don't i have it from
drinks
let's go i have it from some sources
that the dude who owns the house has
friends
in the city there you go who could help
facilitate the change but that doesn't
mean it's right but yeah that's not the
democratic process and and you know i'm
all for you having homies but they have
to have boundaries when it comes to
their influence
but also i mean look look at the pros
play
on on courses that uh that have houses
on them and occasionally you're gonna
get some
but that doesn't mean you either move
the tee boxes or the ocean be it's all
part of it like golf was made like so
if you were affluent you could play but
if you didn't you could play those
courses right there and you could just
you know for to grow the game with kids
fathers and sons like that and if some
dude's like living there the balls are
coming in this house he's like man i'm
going to [ __ ] call my buddy and tell
him to move these tee boxes either up
where you might you'll miss it like if
it's up here you got the view and they
move it down
then you're not
you're losing the view of the ocean yeah
100 percent i mean that's the best part
the view that's it yeah everywhere you
go to to uh
you go to hawaii
and you know you go strolling arm in arm
with your lady
and look at the look at the ocean for
just a little bit of the ocean or you
can play 18 holes and see
the ocean on like 12 12 of the 18 holes
yeah
where have you played in hawaii
well i played uh let's see there's some
ipas now i played in um
let's see i played in maui you played
kapalua played plantation yeah i played
plantation yeah i played that i played
in the uh it was a mercedes back then
yeah you all the mercedes dealers uh
play
and then this stuff it's the if you win
on the pga tour the first tournament
used to be in in uh kappa louis i played
right there
and uh they were you played with all
mercedes dealers so
sam jackson and cheech and myself and
dennis hopper who was who played whoa
good game and he was a little bit sick
at that time and
she's just like hey man we're gonna go
over here
dennis hopper
so i'm with the i'm with my my team and
you know [ __ ] guys over there and i
went and sat with them you know
and uh the dude got me thrown out of the
hotel
what did you get thrown out for yeah for
[ __ ] not sitting with my team at the
dinner
really because you sat with samuel l and
uh yeah those dudes luke wilson if i got
thrown out another year when he got back
to the hotel she was packed
it was at the front because he goes i
couldn't even go back to my room like
when i got there and i had all my stuff
in front i'm like well what about all my
like my estate my toothbrush and stuff
because they had it all packed up real
nice and they had a car getting ready to
take me out [ __ ] hilarious like what
did you do he goes just [ __ ] drinking
and just [ __ ] around
if i could throw it
yeah amazing it's hard to get thrown off
the [ __ ] property in the [ __ ]
hotel yeah that's tough
dude
do celebrities take the competition
pretty seriously because i remember i
saw like ray romano and kevin james oh
that they did like a little documentary
about them playing a celebrity like
pro-am or something and there was
moments where they got like super tense
with one another where ray was like hey
don't talk to the pros like that when
don't say good shot to them when it's a
mediocre shot and then kevin james was
like dude just get out of my face i
understand like i don't need what about
when he goes uh i've lived uh
like he goes i've lived 45 years without
your attention goes oh okay it's gonna
be like that that was a pretty good
documentary it was real so hbo did a
documentary
called making the cut
i'm in the i'm in the beginning of it
because they did that 3m challenge and
they and ray romano
uh was trying to make the cut he took it
so seriously
so so ray romano was a member on
lakeside you know so every year
the the the first t they call your name
and and ray gets so [ __ ] so [ __ ]
neurotic man
so i would start
hitting balls like the day after
thanksgiving like you know we're all
trying to be you know we're getting
ready for the att so thanksgiving the
day after it was friday i go out there
raise out there and then ray goes are
you worried about the
first tee shot uh of that tournament i
said ray it's [ __ ]
in february bro yeah because when i'm
out here you know you know how he talks
like the water
going over it in my head
so
i played in front of him and we played
at spyglass yeah
so we're about to hit our
second shot and you hear all this
[ __ ] noise and stuff and we're like
what the [ __ ] and he was on the first
tee
going this way he hit it [ __ ]
sideways
it went over the over the people's heads
almost [ __ ] killed him into the
driving range and everybody started
laughing and that was the sound that we
heard like somebody had a good shot
he's hitting it he's hitting it this way
he [ __ ] hit it off the end of the
club over the people's heads onto the
driving range amazing that's the [ __ ]
that he was worried about the day after
thanksgiving he goes yeah i'm so nervous
on that first team [ __ ] almost
whiffed yeah
well do you think that that's like i
feel like if you're playing too much or
you're like thinking about it too much
like if i take like a break uh you know
a month or two then i play beautifully
my first round and then i kind of get in
my head a little you know what what what
is it about a [ __ ] sport that the
less you play the
it's better crazy yeah you don't [ __ ]
you guys because i haven't played in
three months you go out there and shoot
like an 81 yeah he goes what'd you shoot
[ __ ] i shot the 39-42 you know you
haven't played you shoot after some
gummies
no well i mean
well then okay then okay guys how about
how about this tournament i might split
her off
so
about
about maybe 10 years ago
i used to take the guys after after
christmas to pebble beach don cheadle
myself anthony anderson
and another one of my friends
so cheeto had some edibles i think he
had like a tootsie roll so on the fourth
hole he ate like half of a tootsie roll
but it's quad strength
so
by the seventh hole it wasn't good he
wasn't getting in the it wasn't getting
it in the air you know the eighth hole
and then the ninth hole he we're like
what's wrong with don he's like oh he
ate that he ate that [ __ ] weed so
on the ninth on the ninth tee box you
could go to the at pebble you can go to
the snack bar
so we went and got vodka cranberries
like legitimate ones and then he took
out the weed i said why don't we all eat
it
and then we'll count every shot on the
way in
so you play nine hole sober
and then at the nine tee box you eat the
weed you bring up two vodka crayons on
the way in and then you count
you're sober for nine
and then the back nine you're you're
[ __ ] high right so
we're counting we're adding them up
and
all of a sudden we're sitting in the in
the chat room and we're like
we need to
[ __ ] we need to do this every year
like we need to
come up with a name
for for this this little you know
tournament and there's a guy named kip
that
there's a there's like a souvenir place
over there that that dude would sell his
mom if she'd put a [ __ ] hat like that
on and hold the pin
that dude was so [ __ ] anything these
glasses belong to ben hogan's caddy
seventeen hundred dollars
these [ __ ] uh bobby jones threw this
into the crowd
12 000
so i went in there and i found this
trophy
a 3 500
trophy from like the 30s
so
those guys said let's call it the
brownie cup
so we played the brownie cup for like
the last maybe seven of the last 10
years
so we've played it with cheech
me cheech
anthony anderson and don cheadle
and
everybody thought cheese was going to
win you know i was like [ __ ] jesus
because he's got the tolerance
but you have to eat it so tommy chong
says
oh no man cheech can't eat
he doesn't do good with edibles he he
smokes
do you guys give him edibles he goes
yeah he goes how did he play [ __ ]
horrible
he [ __ ] hit him so we have to count
every shot right so we played nine holes
we have some drinks we had the weed on
the 11th hole he [ __ ] hit eight balls
[ __ ] sideway eight
and he's like give him another ball
[ __ ] you can't even count that high
and i cheat you're out and you think
he's out and then we hit and we hit
[ __ ] four [ __ ] to the left and
[ __ ] don cheadle wins with a [ __ ]
11 on the 18th hole
he wins by two here [ __ ]
[ __ ] balls playing there in the water
and we're adding them up and [ __ ] man
you he wins with an 11 like it was like
132 to
129.
and every year
oh man they were
crazy high
and every year we try to do it and it's
like that so i think anthony talked
about it on jimmy kimmel
and then somebody said you guys know how
to ought to do like a uh pay-per-view
uh
brownie cup oh yes but did you start did
you start burning
early or late like when did you get into
so so
in life yeah uh
i smoked it a little bit in in uh in
junior high
but that was bad that was bad weed
everything we didn't get good weed till
thai stick was
the sticky until that stuff like in high
school in the late 70s
not like now i mean you we would have
never thought that it would have been uh
legalized right
right
in when he never i never would when he
was on patrol if you had a joint it was
a felony to have
a [ __ ] joint on
just imagine
in the 70s you get pulled over you got a
single joint
that was a felony wow could you see
which drugs were like worse for people
just from who you had to deal with while
on patrol like could you tell that weed
wasn't that bad and that other drugs
were like gnarlier we didn't you know
your the realities are you're young you
know the law they tell you this
and then it just up to individuals i i
had compassion somebody had a single
joint on them
i'm not going to take them to jail
because that that
it's like catching a little fish just
throw them back in the water right you
know you get it with some kilos then you
want to mount them on your wall now
you're going now you're going to jail
but back then in the 70s there was that
there was barbiturates you know there
were reds they called them reds and
bennies
and it was the beginning of pcp
recycling uh came out in heroin
heroin
automatically you know you were gone
because you're using hair and you were
no good right yeah because what about
black beauties
didn't know anything about block you
guys know about the black beauty no
they call them black mollies but
we never saw in east la you saw weed
heroin reds and bennies
and then pcb came in and pcp took over
everything once pcp took over and in the
very end before i left patrol i saw
cocaine once
that was it cocaine wasn't no wow and
that was from an informant whose husband
had just been picked up she comes hey he
left this white powder here you know so
i said put it out by the bush i'll be by
right now went and picked it up just
wrote up a foul narcotics
and you know if they could make a
recreational coke
wouldn't that be [ __ ] great man
you don't hit anybody or you don't
maybe you get a little thinner right but
you don't want to lose your house or you
know
you don't lash out at your family yeah
you don't always start a business you
look great what's going on
cocaine and and meth
uh really messed with people's minds you
know
in our context pcp for a while once he
got rid of pcp because you'd go nuts and
they were impervious to pain with pcp
yeah right well you know
you painted myth that they're they you
get paranoid you get all kinds of [ __ ] i
had to be really careful because i was
losing weight and they thought i was the
goalie from the mighty ducks
yeah goldberg have you seen that dude he
was on the streets
i think what was that that guy's name
the goalie for the mighty things that's
his name in the goldberg yeah yeah
he lost a bunch of weight oh man he no
he was living on the street like no
really
yeah yeah oh that's tragic is great he's
in heavyweights too i love that dude let
me pull up a bigger picture dude
oh man you got to see this [ __ ] it's
crazy
there's a new cocaine in colombia too
that they're doing now i'm colombian and
they're doing something called like
dusay or something whoa no way
i mean come on man man
aaron i don't know if you can get this
on the street which one which one is the
one that oh yeah that's a bummer that
was how they found him here i mean come
on man yeah that [ __ ] he looks like a
sculptor in that right one
yeah like a fun card artist
yeah does it i don't know
what's
what's the new one in colombia i just
heard there's a new pink kind of cocaine
in columbia that everybody's doing
called like i don't know the name it's
like to say or do say or something like
that who says sugar candy right you can
probably
i'm sure it pops up on google but yeah
it's like kind of the new craze over
there but it hasn't i don't think it's
made its way stateside yet you know i'm
supposed to go with kids to to uh
colombia in uh
in april i'll let you guys come back and
i'll let you guys know okay so yeah pink
pink cocaine is a synthetic lucinogen
known as 2cb and has no relation to
cocaine hydrochloride
it's uh pink cocaine and other synthetic
drugs recently emerged as popular party
drugs in south america yeah it's like
all the rage everybody's doing it
i didn't think there would be new drugs
i thought we were done with dr i mean
yeah but new ones pop up all the time
pink cream
sounds nice
yeah it looks easy to mark it let me see
let's see let me see
looks like peeps
oh man that's nice wow that's like
cotton candy yeah it looks tasty
don't do it kids
kids don't
yeah
[Music]
cheers what uh what music are you guys
into now like are you into any old
school like any of those uh i love live
shows i love like uh i love early 2000s
hip-hop 90s hip-hop 90s rock and i'm
into like funky like house as of late
yeah like that's more sort of modern
stuff but is that like the dj's in vegas
yeah i'm into this guy purple disco
machine he's like he's not he's not he's
not like one of the big mainstream guys
but he's like never heard of him just
check him out he's fun no [ __ ] yeah i
like him and what does he do graham
purple disco machine yeah i think he's
european
i've been showing everyone yeah it makes
you want to dance
where does he or does he put where would
you where would somebody see him i was
looking up
he's mostly playing in europe those
[ __ ] dudes make like how much should
we make like a million dollars a night
oh the vegas guys and then there's res
yeah i think i think it's the best job
in the world i've seen dj's like up
close doing their job and i'm just like
and i you know it's like
probably a little tougher than it seems
but you look at him you're like that's
the best gig you could ever have yeah
you just get the whole dance floor
pumped up and everyone's just staring at
you you know those [ __ ] are
like free to set them up with the
chainsmokers one time this guy in san
antonio is like this big defense lawyer
yeah and he just hires everybody you
know every anybody falls he's right
there you know this guy uh
his name and he's married to a latina he
had this thing he had me
enrique iglesias
little john
the chainsmokers
at a had a [ __ ] party for his
employees
whoa so little john's up there what okay
and they [ __ ] talk about it one more
song
you know i [ __ ] cut and cut enrique
glasses down and cut little john down
the chain smokers go out there just like
[ __ ] two hundred fifty thousand two
hundred fifty thousand hundred thousand
hundred fifty thousand
just [ __ ]
damn paying all that money man yeah yeah
and for the employee party and you know
they make it look like that it's got
like a
yeah yeah he's got a little there's a
little flash drive
i'll tell you what i'm going to stick
yeah yeah
[ __ ] a little
you guys ready yeah
this is like a dummy [ __ ] screen
puts that [ __ ] in there all that all of
that is just
for show right right right spinning you
know just make it look like it's turning
the guys like put it in there and
that's it
predetermined
and yeah and going yeah and if you're
the chance smokers they're making 46
million a year in their vegas residency
so basically every show they're making
almost a million dollars if they do one
a week almost a million bucks a show wow
yeah we're friends with the dj and he
his life just but it's crazy hours yeah
like yeah they go on at least
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah you fly to the
next city it seems a little attached
yeah yeah steve aoki and
and those guys but i think steve aoki
maybe not as much right the chain
chainsmokers i think the chainsmokers
did the halftime of the niners and the
rams game we were there i was at that
game yeah you guys were there i think
that was the best regular season game in
history yeah it was insane you were you
you were there too yeah yeah the chiefs
and rams yeah yeah the chiefs in the
rounds that was incredible yeah oh wait
what game are you saying um they were
there yesterday oh yesterday oh they
were there yes
oh man i'm an idiot so they were there a
couple years ago they had to make it
look like they were busier than they
were so they had like a [ __ ] ramp out
there in the middle of thing and one guy
was over here and one guy's over here
just walking in the middle of it because
if not they're just standing in the in
the middle of the they could [ __ ] do
it on that
you gotta get your fist pump
like that yeah
yeah
gotta get the rage i mean you know the
the the big thing is to see um
what the super bowl halftime show turns
out to be yeah snoop dogg and kendrick
lamar
and emily mary j blige
yeah it's gonna be sick that's gonna be
great
who you got winning it
you know uh who do you got killed i got
the ramps and i'm not a pro
let's say right now i'm not a pro
football fan at all i just went with the
rams
because
kaepernick was the guy from san
francisco that started all the kneeling
down and i'm
i'm not there so i wanted to ram someone
so that's the first game probably in
four or five years since kaepernick went
down that i've watched from beginning
so colin kaepernick took a knee and you
you you you disagree with that yeah i do
yeah i do but so you stopped watching
football because of it all together and
i pulled my thing from the nfl
he went against he said he took me but
then a military guy told him that the
way to honor
is to take a knee i don't care what that
military guy said kaepernick took a knee
because he was against law enforcement
he was against cops beating the [ __ ] out
of people and doing and so am i
there's nothing that gives cops a
dirtier name than cops that go rogue and
do [ __ ] to bring
uh what about cops that pull chicks over
that are good looking and then never
leave them alone until they agree to go
out with them
that's awesome that's all bad i think
you make it sound like a bad i had a
girl that i was dating just like
her over really she was attractive and
then she's like this guy won't leave me
alone yeah i mean anytime cops do
anything that are bad and and
we need an internal affairs we need
criminal internal affairs because not
all cops like anybody else are good at
any time anybody goes
bad like that it brings
it makes all of us look bad
so he was protesting
law enforcement when he did it and and
he has the right to do whatever he wants
to do but
as a tax paying
exactly he did it so okay my personal
protest you want to do that against cops
and against the united states of america
the flag whatever you're doing for
my protest is you won't get a nickel of
my money anymore i didn't go out and
wave a flag i didn't go to anything i
just stopped paying money so i cut my
nfl sunday ticket i stopped supporting
all teams when everybody started taking
a knee that's a big deal though because
you you love football and i i did i love
football
but i also
served in vietnam and i was also a cop
for 38 years
so you do what you got to do partner i
do what i got to do
and it's the first time yesterday's game
my son my wife and myself we sat there
and we watched the game from beginning
yeah to end it was a great game great
game glad to have you back
so would you go to the super bowl if you
had a ticket
yeah guys would you guys go yeah i i i
would yeah oh to the super bowl how
would i go right oh my god yeah without
question yeah
i liked kaepernick only because it's
the super bowl and because
it's
you know just like what i've said about
paul i don't care who the president is
i'd be proud to meet the president
whether i believe in his political abuse
or not whoever is the leader i'm happy
to meet anybody
to have the ability to say i was at the
super bowl
and i love football okay how about this
how about the pro bowl is sunday mm-hmm
how about we all go to the pro bowl in
las vegas
vegas is my favorite city in america
right i can get
i'm mr raider
oh yeah you're a raiders fan yeah oh
yeah nice you know why i'm a raiders fan
so so
my [ __ ] turned off when you when you
watch the super bowl
there's a in atlanta they did
the thing about everybody that
is about atlanta big boy and little john
everybody from milan they do a thing
about atlanta
so
in la they asked me to do a thing with
all the people that are known for being
in los angeles and it'll play in the
opening of the super bowl
and then they said uh you you want to
like ad-lib one and i said you know how
about a team that you go up watching in
los angeles and then they leave for 25
years and [ __ ] come back and it's
like they have hey i'm home and you're
like [ __ ] you [ __ ] like your dad
left because back yeah 25 years later
is your mom home hey [ __ ] get the [ __ ]
out of here man
when she got remarried
so so uh i when the rams left i became
uh
and the raiders came out here yeah i
became a raiders dude
because
wherever you went to go get gas wherever
you went to go get beer wherever you
went to go get uh a a half pint of sea
grams you could find a raider t-shirt a
raider towel a raider hat and that's you
know the gas stations
gas station and just that's that's what
made those dudes like that whole ice
cube 30 for 30 with nwa and the
restaurants and all that stuff is like
so you know by moving to vegas it's made
him less violent the the crowd
you know over here i mean there was
everyone's getting ripped off
everybody's getting in chingasa there
are fights it doesn't seem like they're
having that problem let me tell you
something
i was at the coliseum on a monday night
the the raiders always play the chargers
on monday night
and uh there's a guy that's walking up
with
a charger hat like just a regular
you know gold and the thing and he comes
back down with a hat with two lightning
bolts on the side like adventures in
babysitting like that little girl had
the yeah
with the [ __ ] thing and he had a foam
number one
uh
finger with the chargers
so he gets up at the at the top of the
thing and he comes down now he's got the
hat with the bulb and he's got the
number one he's going like this
and as soon as he passes these these
cholo dudes all in black in the right
one dude gets up
and pushes him from behind like with
both hands in the from behind and that
dude goes flying you know the colosseum
all yeah yeah [ __ ] cement all the way
down
goes down there guy bounces up like that
and everybody stands up and they're like
raiders
[Laughter]
so the [ __ ]
so they bring the paramedics come down
with the gurney
like the the one where they strap you
it's not that wheels but they had like
six guys carry you
and uh they put them in there they strap
his head he's got the strap there he's
got the number one
it's like
it's wrapped around him so it's like
this but he still has the hat and
they're now they're carrying them back
up where he came
they stopped serving beer after a half
time oh my god they stopped certain
beers at kickoff all right
that [ __ ] was so f and these [ __ ]
there were these guys behind us that
were going runners and they're just like
[ __ ] well these guys [ __ ] shut the
[ __ ] up same game and we look back
and they're holding a sheet and they're
on tv
all in the sheet and it says like
raiders something and when you look at
the sheet it says property of the la
county jail
they stole the [ __ ] sheep from the
county jail they [ __ ] spray paint
black and silver
on monday night football you can't see
it and you can see it in the game and
then you see it and then the little
little stencil yeah that's incredible
let's go to the uh let's go to the pro
bowl dude down all right good love that
jet sweet x
the girl who started dating is a raiders
fan
oh yeah her family has season tickets
yeah oh she's from reno
who's that they tell us
tell us about us no
it's like
not bad
yeah there's a lot of hot chicks over
there yeah there is yeah
if we went what would it be like the
[ __ ] maintenance crew like oh yeah
that's it somebody must have spilled a
drink what's the oldest dude in one of
those shows
probably us
probably me yeah
i'm 34 i'm probably the oldest one there
yeah
we uh
yeah we went to dodger game we stood at
the
hard rock uh it's a hard rock hotel
it's a hotel right across the street
from the from san diego stadium and
right
in san diego yeah yeah that's yeah hard
rock
and my wife and i stood there a couple
of years ago
and we looked like the
senior grandparents in that place oh and
the whole hotel everybody was young
nobody looked like they were over 30
years old
but there's some cities where it's like
it's there's no age range like if you go
to like that's what i like about vegas
and miami is i think you can be any age
and be in like the nightclub and it's
actually kind of uh i'm not saying
understood in chill
no no
i think when you're
you know if you're older than 50 you
know there's some [ __ ] you get hired
with clothes
right accessories accessories but when
you get to be i mean look at us
[ __ ] like we're in the muppets
in the [ __ ] balcony this is it what
do i do what do i do with my walking
stick showed up my ass yeah well hey and
it's not like you're saying all these
[ __ ] chicks are looking at it say put
your [ __ ] cane away this morning
okay
[Music]
i think when we go to vegas after the
pro bowl we should go to zuke for a dj
show and i think you two should come
with us
do you like to dance
who doesn't like i did
aaron aaron you like to dance
[Music]
okay here's my dude right here
so
that's the guy that gruden
offended
right remember oh in the emails
yeah
oh that's a donor smith is that his name
the uh the head of the players union
yeah he's like a lawyer for them so this
was us at the opening day of
of raider football right there
whoa oh that's awesome so this guy i'm
gonna text him right now i'm gonna say
we need some tickets to the pro bowl on
sunday and he's going to be like how
many do you need
he's been doing that job for a while
right
so he's well
allegedly he told me that
you know the stadium in la i mean that's
they went over budget like yeah they did
but how many like [ __ ] three billion
dollars yeah it was
they don't think they'll ever recoup
their money
so
they put two billion dollars in the
ground because it's built on a
earthquake fault
so when they get down in there the
surveyors they're like it's not a
[ __ ] fault so they put the stadium on
like rollers rollers
so if there was an earthquake and this
was a stadium it could move around it's
not stationary so it's in there like on
springs
so if the if the big earthquake came
it wouldn't snap or anything like
downtown you know the things fall apart
it would just kind of move amongst in
its in the straps of it
so they go there's two billion dollars
that people won't see we went over there
when they were building it and it's hard
to believe that when you see it like
from yesterday and you see everything
they're all people
that
i was there when it was just dirt and
they had the columns in the ground you
know like on straps but
they would have to win
this super bowl
and maybe
two or three others within the next five
years right yeah to even get close to
recouping that money right yeah because
it's like a lot of money i was looking
it up so uh 2.5 billion over budget with
some reports
and you know what that's the 2.5 they
put in the ground for the
the game yeah it's nuts
yeah
so
all right guys we're going
i'm like super down it's about to happen
yeah
um are you guys bringing plus ones
we can bring false ones
i'm supposed to see my dad this weekend
bingo i'm supposed to go to idaho just
so you just say you're going we'll cut
it out yeah i think your dad can do it
dude i mean i'm sorry
by my dad
have you and your dad rage in vegas yet
no i think that's a pretty pivotal thing
for
everybody like see your dad on the dance
floor what's the difference between like
a rage like you say hey have you your
dad raged in vegas like how do i know if
we're raging
right oh that's a good question i don't
know if it's like a specific activity i
think it's more of a mindset like have
you let go completely
of all of your typical responsibilities
and how you feel like you need to
present yourself in those
responsibilities and have you let
yourself be like your pure
that's a great and just a person like
chasing excitement and fun that's how
you know if you've switched into raging
it's your mindset
see i haven't heard this [ __ ] great i
haven't i haven't heard this [ __ ] if
you've listened
i mean i remember the id and the super
id i mean that was you know
that's the mind that's it's up here yeah
i think that it is like your raw self
that is just looking for
excitement and pleasure and uh
and like more raw uh kind of experiences
yeah and then your appetites and your
emotions and stuff like that
and then you got like your super ego
that's keeping all that in check that's
telling you hey no you got
responsibilities you got you got things
you got to take care of and you can't
just let yourself be you know totally
beholden to those desires but when
you're in vegas and you're raging those
desires are front and center you know
but ethically of course remember the the
you know i see an example
so i think the the patriots won a super
bowl that they looked like they were
going to lose is that the one against
seattle where atlanta was the two
atlanta and seattle yeah so tom brady
was like there was maybe like a minute
and a half left or a few couple minutes
left and he's sitting on the sideline
and like a quarterback show the
quarterback just sitting there and he's
looking up and they look like they're
gonna lose
and then
they intercept the pass or they stop the
guy
and they show him and he's jumping
up and down and this is a dude that's
got more money he's got [ __ ] super
bowl championships and i think that's
what it is
where he's like a kid man he's just
jumping up and down by himself he can't
believe it like it's just changed so
much within a span of five minutes we're
sitting there like [ __ ] we lost and that
[ __ ] and i and when you see that in a
guy i think that's what it is right
there you're just out of your [ __ ]
mind like you don't care who's watching
yeah when you're you're away it doesn't
matter how much money you have doesn't
matter who you are
you play football as a kid and you play
with your teammates you've had hundreds
of teammates and in that moment that you
thought
the whole world is watching me lose
[ __ ] two minutes later you win it's
game time he's a pro
it's game time the guy that uh if that
guy catches that ball the 49er catches
that ball
uh the interception yeah number three
yeah he just dropped that it was like a
basket catch
he's not sleeping oh my god no he stood
a long time down the ground crying too
really [ __ ] catches it
it's over it's the other way yeah
did you play sports i played uh baseball
in in high school nice i loved it i
loved baseball
i wish i had i quit i broke my wrist and
i stopped playing in like fifth grade
but that was the one sport i was like i
should have stuck you like playing
baseball oh did you break your
yeah and you know i didn't know it was
broken for like a week
and that was in the game i was in the
all-star game fifth grade and i was
trying to throw and i would you know
forward like that and the ball would
just go to the right
i think my wrist is [ __ ] up
exactly what i said to my dad i'm like
yeah this is [ __ ] up dad yeah
you know what hey now a kid falls you
take that [ __ ] urgent care
they're like he's fine
yeah he fell off the couch
this i have a little scar right there i
was working on my bike i cut myself this
whole thing had gangrene in it and it
was here i went to the doctor to cut it
and it was pushing [ __ ] out i looked at
it and the doctor said
three days later you lose that finger i
can't remember and i was [ __ ] walking
around with his [ __ ]
black finger
dude gangrene and i finally couldn't
take it anymore i told my grandmother
look at this she's like what the [ __ ]
i remember the dude just squeezing that
[ __ ] out of there it's like
you didn't think about the doctors like
you didn't [ __ ] think about telling
anybody
so i don't think it was a [ __ ] big
like and now kids it's everything
they've fallen yeah straight to but back
then
you know
when i when i went to high school i i
loved baseball
and i was a catcher and
trying out for the team when
everything's going good
come the final cut day says ah gil sorry
so you know hey you're you're great
behind the plate and you got a stick
but we're building our team on speed
and you ain't got speed but he says i'd
like to hang around with the team
but we're gonna have to cut the team and
you
i said dawg thank you very much and i
just
never was fast enough i was too slow
you know i don't want to cry now
i'm a [ __ ]
can you look up my first pitch in
chicago that i threw at wrigley field
yeah
how nervous were you for that
i was warming up across the street from
the four seasons in a in a park where
we could have been either killed or
bought not not ping cocaine but but you
know
i warmed up for two traditional ones
yeah
this one
oh that's that's an alley that's a good
one too no no let's see that one i'll
just make it bigger
check this out
if you're listening adrian adrian
gonzalez caught the
card i remember i used to pitch i
pitched in high school pitched in little
league
and i warmed up i warmed up i was
warming up there we go i'm wait i'm you
know i'm nervous
i'm not i'm
watch this and i get i get to it i get
it to that mound
here we go watch this
last thing you said was
once you go with my grandparents to
these i just sit right there in the
check this out
dude that's a good [ __ ] that was a
strike cash money
why were you more nervous for that or
the emmys
i think i might have been more nervous
for that yeah
the robin williams will
but that one if you if you bounce it or
you don't reach it
yeah i mean that's kind of like it's
forever you're in your church your
cathedral of going to the left field
pavilion with my grandparents in the 60s
and 70s and then going back and doing
that
it's pretty big yeah
that's cool but it ain't going to be
like this weekend
that stadium is now in las vegas
great stadium will probably be in the
mgm owner's suite
it's not as sweet as more like a villain
probably got a hundred together that he
came over to me and he goes you know
this is called a sweep but
there's 120 seats in here it's more like
an auditorium but yeah they make it a
sweet i mean yeah the crazy [ __ ] you've
ever seen dude
and there we are
might be even better than the super bowl
all your favorite players yeah playing
against each other in one game in vegas
that's awesome i'm looking forward to it
yeah we're going i got to talk to my dad
are we really going oh let us are we
really going yeah we're going okay cool
gil
yes i already said yeah yeah
i'm uh i didn't even look in the
calendar right
friday i'm going to fly into vegas on
saturday and then we'll
where's your show friday and corpus
christi but i think oh nice
either at the four seasons or
the am is the official raider hotel but
as soon as we're out of here
we're making the uh proper arrangements
corpus christi cool town on the water
it's cool man yeah and they got the
selena memorial there yeah you've been
there once yeah
cut my hand open
over there yeah dancing on a rock i
slipped and cut it on coral reef had to
take a vest but in the er
i was dancing to the bee geez on a rock
trying to show off for some people and i
slipped and cut my hand on some uh
some coral reef there you showed that
like an oyster shell wait a minute but
what were you doing
what was i doing in corpus christi
i don't know my daughter wants to go
because she wants to go to like the to
the museum right right there's a statue
right there on the water yeah of celina
yeah yeah my family went to visit the
selena memorial my mom's a huge fan yeah
did she go to the days inn
where the accident happened i don't
remember doing that no i just remember
the memorial so you know they you know
that whole day like you know that
that whole thing happened where she got
shot and
she went into the days in
and collapsed right there
and i went over there you know i was
working at corporate and i i said hey
man we got to go to like the days in
and uh i said excuse me and the guy goes
yeah yeah yeah right here
a thousand times a day
yeah yeah yeah right here and he turns
away goes oh hey what's up i said hey
man he goes oh [ __ ] you won't believe it
i [ __ ] a thousand times a day nobody
wants a room
they just [ __ ] want to see where she
fell and it's like [ __ ] man yeah yeah
that makes sense i mean
but then they have i think they have a
mu the museum now right
maybe this was decades ago when i went
but but also but also
uh almost like you like i think her the
rel the beliefs and the religion did not
allow for like blood transfusions
oh so she could have been saved
i'm not gonna say alleged right but
we're just speculating what what her
what her family believed was that
they're not into the
into into blood transfusions
interesting
jehovah
maybe
you go to the gravesite it has like the
mask of them like there's a mask of her
on her
on her headstone
oh interesting you know chicanos man we
love that [ __ ] man
chicanos we're more we're more attracted
to the dead than to the living
the [ __ ]
i bet
we went to uh on vacation we were in
france and
we'll see jim morrison's great some of
the people wanted to go to the louvre
to go see uh the mona lisa you know yeah
yeah
been yes
and my wife said well i want to go you
know there was like
five couples
and four of the couples were going or
three of the couples were going and i
said you know i i really don't feel like
going to the museum so i feel like i
said okay if you want to go
i said but god damn it you know we grew
up in l.a you've never asked me once to
take me to the museum in l.a you've
never asked me to take anything to go
see anything like that now it's a little
bit different in the louvre and so they
went to louvre i didn't go and nor did
she she finally changed her mind she
didn't go to the loop the other couples
did add the couples out of the three
couples that went one
other people one of the ladies
because she's a tough little broad she
fought her way up there because it was
so packed it was oh yeah [ __ ] elbow
she got her way up and she actually got
seen the damn thing's only about this
big you know small
it's not a great big painting and so
i'm not one bit sorry i missed it
seriously seriously what's in the move
the wing victory yeah i was gonna say
that's the other big ticket one that i
know of his wing victory which one's
wing victory
i'm with you i think
i think the money is overrated
yeah i think the mona lisa is overrated
and it is surprisingly small i mean like
when i looked at it i was like i don't
know why this is how did it get
right it seems kind of arbitrary i'm
like why this
i've been to spain
that's it though phoenix de milo also in
the louvre yeah yeah
she's probably a soucia
that's like she had a name back in the
day she was have you seen that document
the lost leonardo no so the documentary
lost leonardo is
another leonardo da vinci
that looks like a male mona lisa so
everybody's like is that a real
leonardo da vinci because it looks like
he just said [ __ ] i'll draw the i'll
just paint the mona lisa as a dude
and it's they're almost set they're so
similar
that they and they found it like they
would be like why would he
why would he uh um paint one like that
but remember like when they did i mean
you know what he's doing the [ __ ]
sculptures that it took forever like
they didn't live forever they [ __ ]
took like 35 years to do
to do you know one of those sculptors
and when you go to rome
there's one that he didn't finish
leonardo da vinci and the knee if you
look at the knee like the knee has the
other knee is like a perfect knee
and the other knee has like a chip in it
and they said that after working on it
for so long because he was i think those
guys were drugging he was drugging
that
he he felt that the statue was talking
to him
because he was on drugs and he threw a
hammer at it and hit the knee and
chipped it so that's that's the that's a
big thing to go see that statue is that
you're standing in front of it and they
said oh you know the knee is
you know like kind of crackers after so
many years of working on it uh alone
the [ __ ] statue started talking
hurry up [ __ ]
or the sistine chapel where before
you could just go in there and stand
there
and and look up because it's on the
ceiling yeah and then they put a [ __ ]
conveyor belt in there so you couldn't
[ __ ] around and stand there
you stand on the belt you go like this
you're [ __ ] moving you're out they
probably put a [ __ ]
conveyor belt in there so that you
didn't you so that you can't stand there
for hours and look at it hmm i don't
remember being i remember going to the
sistine chapel i don't wear the conveyor
belt was like well about five years ago
i think about five six years ago was
there
i got now they got a moving walkway
that's what we walk with yeah i wanted
to you were talking about how people
uh you were saying
were you saying like mexican people like
love death more than like
yeah my mom's colombian i'm colombian
yeah my mom's like the most amazing
person i've ever met with death like if
we go to a funeral and it's like open
casket she'll hug the body and i'm sure
it's very distinct cultures but my mom
has like this incredible comfort and
almost like comes alive more when she's
surrounded by death and i've always been
very impressed by that what did she say
about that
i don't know i've talked to her about it
but
she like loves celebrating death like if
it's like the day that someone died my
mom will always like candles she'll
always talk about them she'll always
like bring out pictures of them she
makes like a big
uh
moment out of at a death and she she
seems she doesn't seem she's sad but she
also seems almost happy and alive when
she's dealing with it you know that's an
interesting thing so so
you know the day of the dead the whole
thing about an altar for somebody who
who is no longer around
and uh coco like the movie coco it's
about death
about death and
you know when when when uh the woman who
played my mom on my tv show had a party
for the day of the dead and then she's
like bring
pictures of people and they put it in an
altar
so there's i don't have the i don't i
don't have the picture but so it was it
was she had these mylar
skull uh balloons you know day of the
dead balloons and the mylar you know
it's on it's on a string so it's it's
kind of turning you know it's kind of
turning
so
we all took a picture
of all of us together and the balloon
when we took the picture the [ __ ]
between our shoulders like right here
the the the
the person looked at the picture and
goes you have to check this out the
[ __ ] balloon
was facing
the camera or before it wasn't right
so when we all got together the there
was like this and then when we took the
picture
it was in between our shoulders like
looking at the camera
and it freaked everybody out that that
it could have been some photo bombed
your picture i photo bombed the picture
man but you know because they they do
they feel it and they sense it like in
the house that i i live in los feliz
we've done talked about it that
it was haunted i mean it's not as much
anymore but but [ __ ] full-on haunted
man
honey
do you sage it we had a lady come in
yeah and people would come in we did a
door dash you know psa
the girl's in there with the you know
she's got the camera there and she and
she's tells momo she goes hey can you
tell the woman in the other room
just to stop talking i can hear her
talking and they're like there's nobody
there's nobody in the other room
you got your place sage right you're
worried about a ghost well so i moved
into a place
place to cry there i was looking at two
places one both for rent one was a
thousand dollars cheaper
and they're about the same place
and so then i learned that someone died
you know a few months earlier
do they have to tell you i think they
have to tell you if it was i don't know
the most recent this man i don't think
they tell you anymore i think
if they died if if they died and now
they're selling the house then they got
to tell you but if they died and
somebody else bought the house now this
person they don't have to go back
and say hey right last owner did you
know or did you know so i was looking in
november the person died in september so
they told me so i didn't even look
inside but now i live across the street
from it so i still saged
because i i don't know if ghosts can
cross the street you know
they have to look both ways
yeah they have to look they have to look
both ways before they do right yeah yeah
well yeah sage i mean they're looking up
i was terrified my first night i saged
it up and i was in bed i was like
because i live alone i was just in
covers do you hear do you hear [ __ ] is
it i hear i heard stuff i could show you
i heard stuff in my
no i my place is fine but let me see if
i can find this picture i've always been
intrigued by that stuff but i've never i
feel like if you if you open yourself up
to it then you're more
likely to but also they say if you um do
not call
they say don't call don't call anybody
to you
right yeah if you if you i was calling
people
i don't even answer phone calls from
george
i would say hey if you're out there you
know let me know your
let me know you're all right that kind
of [ __ ] they say don't do that oh yeah i
did a really good horror movie that came
out during the pandemic i think it's
called the host yeah it's like all over
zoom and it's that's like the premise is
that they're doing a seance and they
like one of the gals ends up [ __ ]
around and like invites someone
in and that's like the ghost who ends up
coming in right i didn't do it any
justice there but that's it's right
along those lines yeah you know what man
they they say don't
there's some there's some don't
encourage a scary movie
out there and i watch it and it was like
it was like a scary comedy
but it was with uh mexicans in it
and the hoods you know
the gangsters were in it and they were
talking street talk and
something comes up and scared little
kids get the [ __ ] out of your arms you
know awesome
and it was like gangster but oh they
were it was scary any idea what it was
called or anyone who's in it or anything
like that it's called let's get out the
[ __ ] out of your homes yeah
i love the name of your podcast by the
way
oh my god hi yeah
the uh
i would walk on stage and you know there
were all these latinos out there and i
would say
there we go
oh my god
then we started doing oh my god and
that's uh
right now arsenio said man you got the
[ __ ] best name for a podcast like who
else is gonna top oh my god hi yeah yeah
i was at uh momo's show thursday night
and i sit back in the back in the green
room until moma went out and then i went
out in the audience and i wanted to
watch a set
and as soon as i walked out there
somebody said hey look there's the beef
squasher there you go
yeah
that's the name of this bill's got his
own he gave me
here on the show
and they're obviously where the
show yeah
by the way on the selena front i was
looking up the blood transfusion thing
so she was a jehovah's witness uh and so
her religion said she couldn't get blood
transfusions but because she was
unconscious doctors didn't know that she
still got the blood transfusion
okay um
so you know eddie van halen and i were
friends
uh and um
sorry the night that he
the night that he passed i said uh
um
i said hey ed let me know you're all
right you know check this out
say something
that's why i distanced myself from this
thing right now
there's some wild [ __ ] going on in my
house this was all
yeah for real the one with the like the
woman in the next room that the sound
lady was picking up that's that's oogie
yeah are ghosts for the most part chill
or are they looking to cause trouble it
depends
i can hear some kind of high pitch noise
right now
oh you can i can yeah i don't know it
might be just my young ears but ghosts
are in that dog whistle register
no i have a dog but yeah they i think
they might be
your election
so i live alone
yeah that sounds like yeah it sounded
like drums almost it sounded like the
opening stance
because you got this [ __ ] played right
here and chad right here
i'm scared
i'm [ __ ] [ __ ]
there's orbs and [ __ ] flying oh oh man
dude there's orbs and
oh yeah i love all that system i got my
aura ready so so so
uh
yeah you still hear them or not what's
up you still hear that [ __ ]
those sounds we didn't hear any sounds
he found out his ghost was hot
and then he was trying to throw a rhythm
and stuff like that oh take down the
sage in brother
that's exactly that you want to go [ __ ]
you while you're sleeping
really a dolphin too
for real there's dolphins that'd be
banging chicks you know what's all that
doing [ __ ] dolphins banging chicks
there's a youtube channel dolphins will
like rape people
for the girl i've seen like when you go
to sea world and you find out about the
culture of dolphins you're like this is
pretty uh savage and they they have like
uh scars on their bottlenoses from all
the uh
you know interactions
all the raging sea dolphins a lot
there's a youtube video of a dude
talking about he's a really weird guy
not the kind of guy you'd want to like
come over or play golf with and he talks
about his relationship with the dolphin
and he had like a sexual relationship
with the dolphin for
several years
and i he talks about it like it was like
mutually uh pleasurable but i'm like how
can you speak on behalf of the dolphin
dog are you talking about the guy who's
on howard stern that's maybe i i watched
him he sounded like he was like a jazz
player he's like just real cool brother
do you remember that he's like he's real
cool brother
a jazz player and a dolphin that seems
like i mean that's yeah so does your mom
put altars out for like
for people that she's lost or
yeah not they're not out all the time
but yeah like when it comes to those
dates where they died my mom's like very
keenly aware of it and she will
do a
like a little ceremony and stuff like
that
it's it's pretty beautiful we put one
out at our house
i forget what they call it though they
it's for dia de los muertos and
it's everybody all our friends and
family anybody that's died
they
put the candles out there it's uh
some people think in our in our culture
we you know we keep death too separate
from our experiences
and that we're we're not in touch with
it enough there was like a novelist carl
von nasgard and he said like we should
leave dead bodies out on the street and
not cover them so people are more aware
of that this is part of the process and
kind of the most
common experience we'll all share yeah
well they smell better that's a strong
[ __ ] yeah it is a strong pitch i don't
know like you know if i'm raging in
vegas i don't know if i want to see a
dead bee there but also i think that
people like talking about raging in
vegas i do think people wait until
something's wrong with them
before they decide they want to live
right totally you know like if you get a
diagnosis of like oh you know i have
this and you're like you always wanted
to go
to spain you always want to travel to
europe and then you decide then but you
know we should be doing that [ __ ] every
day because you you don't you know
because you don't know you don't know
that's a bit like yogis say you have to
live as if a katana is hanging above
your head at all times no question yeah
yeah and the buddha's as if what's
hanging above like samurai sword by
string so could just you know yeah live
every day like it's the pro bowl
right live every day like it's you know
when they when you when you get that
[ __ ] interception thrown at you
catch it catch the [ __ ] and 49
other guys celebrate you drop it and i
mean i mean that's a big deal huge he'll
live with that for the rest of us and if
you remember there was another guy
williams who his i mean kenny williams i
think he's the general manager of the
white sox his son played for the niners
and
he fumbled the punt
a few years ago they would have gone to
the super bowl then
the dodger first baseman that had the
ball go through his legs
that lost that one that one yes i mean
for the rams i mean
it's kind of the best situation for them
but for the 49ers to come to l.a
beat the
whatever beat the rams they would have
stayed in town
and stayed for two weeks i mean they've
been living the life
that's supposed to be the craziest party
in the world is that weak ramp up to the
super bowl yeah
that's like when michael irvin would
just go nuts and just be
doing blow skiing those dudes are in a
cat suit like a [ __ ] purple [ __ ]
onesie
just
those dudes had the white house in
dallas dude i just read that book about
that it's pretty hilarious
boys will be boys boys will be boys by
jeff perlman and there's a quote by nate
newton at the top of the chapter where
he's like he's talking to the press and
he's like you know we're just trying to
be considerate and we got a house we're
running horrors in and out of and people
want to get mad at us for that
like he wants credit that they have this
house where they do all their deeds yeah
and he's like no we're being responsible
why are people getting mad at us for
this like we're actually being very
we're gonna have the cowboy cafe i went
to the cowboy cafe and i guess that got
too like
too much press too much coverage and
then so they just got a house on a
suburb street so that latino guy anthony
montoya that guy paco that's in the book
i knew that i knew that guy oh really
his family had a rosita's restaurant on
like uh
harry hines
he was kind of like the gopher for
michael irvin i was hanging out with
those guys at that time i went to the
cowboy cafe one night all those guys
were nate newton and was it crazy
[ __ ] crazy man
reading about michael irvin i'm like
inspired by him though i know he gets
into a lot of trouble and he does a lot
of things wrong but he's so committed to
the team and he's such a hard worker and
it seems like he was like a real
leader despite all those other things
despite all that other [ __ ] they they
used to go and play like that's where
the guys would really kind of like
accelerate their behavior where they
would go from town to town and the
cowboys would play
whoever the local new celebrities in
town
and uh and basketball is a big dude yeah
that's pretty nuts so up in sacramento
alleged
that michael irvin was on the bench and
he had two chicks making out with each
other
it says in the book that they would have
orgies and that michael irvin was oh my
god in charge of uh directing them
really and he'd be like hey you get
behind her and then you get in front and
like he had like a like a genuine gift
for being able to uh
to orchestrate orders and then you think
a guy like that if you got on tv would
not want to be noticed you know my kind
of mild-mannered clothes yeah i think
too right like
hide-and-seek we got to do this
you think it'd be like low-key like just
like you know i'm trying not to draw
attention to myself but those guys were
[ __ ] rogue man
they were rogue and even if you see like
i went to
i went to the super bowl when michael
jackson performed when the cowboys won
the first super bowl at the rose bowl 93
michael jackson performed and that's
when uh um
leonlette was running with the ball and
don beebe knocked him over behind
knocked him down so leona picks up the
fumble and he's running like right in
front of us and you see
he's got like a 20-yard head start and
he's running and don bieby had that
big-ass
uh gazoo helmet remember mr the great
gazoo from the cartoons big ass helmet
and he's [ __ ] running you see the
little dude [ __ ] running and the and
and lee only [ __ ] catches him man
like in the five yard line puts his
hands on like that [ __ ] knocks the
ball out of his hands like all happens
in front of us oh wow yeah and that kind
of defines him it's like what we're
talking about you know life-defining
moment you either define the moment or
the moment to fight
yeah
all you do is hold the ball cross the
line turn around
and he was just
he let up he's let up well i hate to be
the time cop gentleman but uh
what are we doing against it we're going
to san clemente we're going to the pro
bowl
we got a nice most of us yeah most of us
are going
bring your dad i gotta go yeah i'll give
him a call
we'll get all the numbers uh uh together
yeah we'll we'll get around the chain
we'll figure it out cool amazing yeah
awesome thank you so much thanks for
coming out guys please plug the plug the
show plug anything you wanna you guys
are promoting right now we have a
podcast going deep with chad and jt it's
on all things comedy as well when does
this come out uh this will probably be i
think two weeks from now so mid february
we'll have a show at the hollywood
improv on the 18th 16th
nice i'm on top of things you have a
show a couple a couple of days from now
on uh the second one
yeah yeah
do you like that club do you do
this it's a different club than when i
was uh
doing the clubs yeah yeah i actually we
uh we just we just fixed this today
actually so at uh chat goes deep.com we
have all our tour dates so you can get
all the links because we're going we're
we have some dates coming up our first
floor yeah we're starting first time i
like that
where are you guys going to go texas
arlington where inside the improvs
uh yeah we're going to
oh
well i'll do the improv we'll check out
the dates and see theaters and small
theaters or venues clubs clubs
we're going to grand rapids michigan
uh detroit arlington
um
i think it's paso robles nice ugly uh
snow and mexican a lot of good wine and
pasta robots so yeah that's right hey so
so you guys when the podcast like it's
generated this thing right where you you
have all your fans like they're
everywhere right it's kind of a
combination of things it's like the
podcast and then like our videos and
stuff like that and then but yeah we're
just doing straight stand up at all the
shows though it's not the pod yeah
are you guys on tick tock and all that a
little bit on tick tock yeah we feel
like what do you think tick tock is is
it is it for you guys you have to kind
of be more into
like my daughter did one with with
santana like you know
dancing and
like took the time to like produce it
you know we're instagram guys yeah and
then i just don't know if i have the
bandwidth for a second app yeah i've
kind of just like we gave it a shot we
did we did some videos on there yeah
it's a lot of us dancing shirtless which
was fun yeah because we felt like tick
tock was kind of like you have to be
horny to be on there it's all horny
horny yeah right so we were trying to
push the horniness front and center yeah
40 30 which was fun because that is a
big part of our souls but yeah hard to
do that everywhere you have a girlfriend
or are you married no i'm just not i
know i'm just dating right now i would
like to to settle down but is dating
okay so is dating
how do you know if it's going to be
exclusive like do you say
uh in the beginning i mean has it
changed since
i mean i don't know it's crazy it's not
bad it's crazy yeah
you you have the conversation at a
certain point yeah yeah
i a lot of people are polly now i'll
have people
throw that out there do you want police
people from utah you know
it's probably like more than one person
it's more than one person but you know
it's like it sounds like a cool idea but
when someone else pitches it to me when
they're like hey i want to be polly
i'm like
i take it a little it hurts me a little
bit i'm like what yeah i think it would
hurt a little bit yeah and you're
talking about just multiple partners i'd
like to be the one who pitches the poly
thing would you get that shot would you
would you move somebody in this is what
they told me and this was in we were
young men
some guy goes uh move a man move him out
that's all the dude had to say we're in
our twenties goes hey i'm living with my
girlfriend the guy goes move them in
move them out
and he goes what does that mean he goes
unless you're [ __ ] planning on
getting married don't move them in yeah
move them in move them out i lived with
this girl in the early mid 80s and it's
like [ __ ]
left me she moved out what did i hear in
my head move them in move them movement
[Laughter]
unless you're going to make that step
yeah don't move them in right but you're
single now
yeah i'm divorced but
very happy man my clubs are very happy
and all my guitars are my house yeah
have you tried a dating app
yes which one did you do i'm on radio oh
nice but you know they go are you on ran
i said you know it's like fishing you
know when when you get throw the hook in
there and then you and your buddies are
having beers and [ __ ] around the
thing oh i got something you just leave
it
exactly
awesome well thanks for coming out you
guys yeah thanks for having us
tatum o'neill but i never took her out
oh nice paper man yeah uh bad news bears
oh yes
i was trying to get her to just say big
wow to me
thanks so much for having us yeah yeah
it was an honor yeah yeah i just feel
like you guys didn't talk i talked most
of the time
you're captivating kind of what we
wanted yeah all right
you